this
is a video that i've been looking
forward to producing for
quite a long time and nobody's actually
asked me to do it none of my viewers or
subscribers
but i think many of them will find it
quite interesting because
what i'm going to be talking about are
books
and specifically tangible
physical volumes that i have a
personal connection with books that i've
carried with me
from place to place that made a huge
impact on me
at different times so with each of these
there is a
personal story that goes along with it
and every one of them is
you know one i would recommend to you to
read anyway
but i i just want to tell you about how
i encountered them and what they meant
to me
at different times so we begin with the
uh
of omar khayyam the fitzgerald
translation
which is quite interesting you know it's
got all this beautiful
artwork in it and you know omar hayam
was a
poet and there's all these great you
know
translations here there's there's a lot
of debate about how
faithful the translations are but i
remember
you know my father had this among his
books
and we had a lot of books left over when
he died when i was
11 and then you know some of them i
discovered in middle school
some of them i discovered in high school
as i did this
and i i liked it i was very
impressed by it i thought it contained
you know wisdom
and it was good poetry and i i would
sometimes
copy the the pictures
in it when i do watercolors i remember
doing that while i was
in the army uh when you know we were
doing like our duty and
and stuff like that in my off time and
this book has gone with me
you know so my my high school was over
30 years ago this book has gone with me
from move to move to move
for 30 years and i don't know what my
dad
found in it or you know whether he just
bought it because it was like something
people were reading at the time
but um i've really i really enjoyed it
and i have
you know gone back to it many times you
can tell that it's
not in the greatest of shape but that's
the story of the rubaiyat
um when i got into college
there were a set of books that i i got
and um two of them are straight out
philosophy
one i got freshman year i'm not sure
where i bought it
but i got this copy of the spoke
zarathustra
and i remember reading it and trying to
puzzle out exactly what was happening i
think i
mis you know mistakenly thought that
nietzsche was writing a coherent work
that would make sense across the entire
uh
you know four parts of it
but i would read it and it was it was
very exciting you know
and i also really like the cover as well
and i i remember spending a lot of time
one of the jobs that i had was a docent
in the art gallery on campus and nobody
ever came in and i'd look
i'd walk around and look at the works of
art every once in a while you know i'd
get to
chit chat with people doing stage work
or stuff like that but
i spent a lot of time reading and this
was one of the books
that i read a lot of i do remember
somebody
actually a professor walking by and
saying oh
you shouldn't be reading that and that
just made me of course want to read it
more
so this is another book that has
accompanied me
everywhere i've gone since
college um so that that's that's a cool
one
this is another one that i i didn't get
that much out of when i first
got it i'd heard it was a good thing to
have the meditations of marcus aurelius
you know i wasn't that into stoicism
when i was an undergraduate
if anything i was into existentialism
and
some you know some marxist stuff some
pragmatist stuff
but i i did you know read and reread
this
and i could tell that marcus was
somebody who was
worth engaging with on my part
so you know this this too this
particular translation
um by rb rutherford
you know has has accompanied me
everywhere i've gone
the next two books aren't directly
philosophy as such but they have some
massive philosophy connections
so i got girdle escherbach
probably i think my freshman year of
college
and you know it's it's quite a tome and
i read my way through it
i was so excited about all the things
going on because i was a philosophy and
mathematics major
so i was into you know like the
foundations of logic and i had friends
who were into
computer science some of them as
computer science majors
some of them on the outside doing
programming one starting his own
business which
he still has today and this was you know
this is like major stuff we actually
talked one
of the um one of the professors
in the math department who also taught
computer science classes
into doing a special topics class
where we went through the entire book
over the course
of a semester and you know talked about
all the different topics
and the different issues that were in it
there were some prereqs for that
if i remember rightly and so this is
this is one again that i have taken with
me everywhere
haven't read it for quite a while i
think maybe this summer i'll
go back and and reread it it could be
quite fun to do
but it made a big impact on me you know
considering gurdwell's incompleteness
uh a theorem and it's it's applications
to any formal system
that ended up playing a role for me in
in graduate school
then we have a work of literature and
it's this particular copy i mean this is
not all of jorge's stories
but it certainly contains some of the
really major
ones the ones that made a huge impact on
me like garden of forking paths
the lottery in babylon which is probably
one of my favorite stories there the
circular ruins
three versions of judas the theologians
i could go on and on and on
at one point i actually wanted to write
a book of commentary on this and i
started doing that
after i finished college in between
college and
graduate school and it never really made
a lot of progress with it but it might
be something that i take up again but
this book you know again came with me
everywhere
uh it actually accompanied me when i
went
on my my trip in between grad
undergraduate and graduate school where
i first went up to quebec with my buddy
ed
uh to montreal and hung out with some of
my relatives there and then went over to
europe and traveled around for about a
month and a half on a year rail pass
meeting up with you know like old
friends and
people like that right before i went to
graduate school in southern illinois and
then i
you know i brought this with me and i
was probably i remember
using this in an aesthetics class the
professor was not super
happy that i was doing that but i i was
such a fan
of borehase and there's so much cool
stuff in there
in these stories obviously there are
better story collections
but this was the one for me and i
remember
for example when i was for a very brief
period living at my
my mother's house after you know after
after undergraduate i lived with a buddy
called
whose name was wild bill for about three
months
and then came down to milwaukee lived at
my mom's place until i got an apartment
over on
on farwell and i remember like sitting
outside
listening to new model army on my
my headphones smoking a cigarette you
know
drinking drinking a miller genuine draft
and reading through these
these stories rereading them for who
knows how many
times so really really great volume
there
and then i and then i got to graduate
school and
while at graduate school i picked up
some some other volumes that were quite
important to me
as well this
is derrida's on gramatology it's the you
know the
french original of it and there's a
special story to this one as well
which is my mom the first year that i
was in graduate school
my mom went over to france
and i don't remember whether it was like
a business trip or
just for fun or something like that but
she asked me is there anything that you
want me to get
and i was getting into a lot of
philosophy of language and i was like
uh you know um get me a good dictionary
get me some darida
um maybe some liveness she also bought
me some live minutes
uh stuff the discord metaphysique
but this you know i i almost wrote my
dissertation on on dairydod before i was
talked out of it
and then switched to talking about hegel
hegel and blondel and then eventually
maurice blondell
and i read and re-read this
so often and it was it was cool to have
it because you know one my family's
francophone um although my generation
most of the kids didn't learn
french and so this played a really
important role
for me you know as a young graduate
student
i really i really enjoyed it and it's
it's one of the things that i have you
know my mother died over 20 years ago
it's one of the things that i have from
her to remember
her generosity this this particular book
that i
have um i used to spend a lot of time in
used bookstores while i was
a graduate student both we'd go to st
louis and there were some amazing used
bookstores there but there was also a
really great one
on the strip in carbondale
and as i was digging around
i found this the works of epictetus now
i'd never actually
read anything beyond the end caridian
when i was an undergraduate
and i thought it's kind of okay it you
know i don't know that i buy all this
stoic stuff but
i didn't know that much about epictetus
and i picked this up in the bookstore
and started reading it through and i saw
that it was talking about the will
and about freedom and about choices and
all this other stuff
if you don't know the discourses so the
end caridian the in the handbook
that's a sort of very short selections
from
the discourses we have four of the books
of the eight books that were written by
aryan
epictetus's student and this is an
older um you know older translation
translated by thomas wentworth higginson
right all these funny english
names and you know i was reading through
it when i was in that bookstore and i
was like this is
this is the stuff i'm interested in this
is about all sorts of cool
topics that tie in with everything from
like character
to the freedom of the will to
you know metaphysics to all this this
great stuff and so this was my real
introduction to
to stoic philosophy beyond marcus
aurelius
because this is much more substantive
and to epictetus
himself there are better translations
out there i don't recommend this one in
particular
but this book will always have this
volume will always have kind of a
special place
in my my heart
i also encountered aleister mcintyre's
work
somebody who i would later have the
opportunity to study with and actually
get to know
a little bit cool guy and
uh they you know i i'd heard references
to it and i found this at the 710
bookstore
was it i think that was the one that um
these two guys started on the strip i
might be mistaking that for
for a different bookstore but um they
had all the cool philosophy stuff as
well as like you know
movies you could rent and things like
that and an espresso machine
so they can make you espresso and this
is the copy that i got
you know it was already in the second uh
edition by then
um and uh
you know i've i've worn it out there's a
third edition now and it's this is
really
quite nice to to have you know
um so
mcintyre after virtue made a major
impact on me there were so many things
where i was like
yeah this is this is what i i've been
trying to
you know think and articulate he finally
put
a name to it and a frame to it so that
was that was quite important
then we can talk about books that are
kind of grad school
and beyond so when i wrote my
dissertation on maurice blondell
i did a lot of work from his
untranslated trilogy and and other
works but the most important work of
blondel has always been oxio 1893
there's two english translations um the
second one by oliver leblanchette is is
quite reliable the first one by james
somerville
you don't really want to have but it was
it was cool at
my dissertation defense you know i
one of the people there was kenneth
stickers who was the current chair of
the
southern illinois university and
carbondale
philosophy department he was the
co-chair for my dissertation because my
mentor garth gillen
had retired and kenneth stickers
um when after we had the thing we went
out you know for
for lunch together and he gave me this
which is the it's not the original of
course right
but this is a french you know
cresce universitaire de de france
edition of
blondel's laccio in 1893 i say during
critique de la vie
est right and so
i've had this ever since and it's it's
really nice to have it's also nice to
have the pages cut
because when i have to do it i screw it
up
another book you know when i
when i was in graduate school i studied
um classical greek
and that opened up a whole world to me
in terms of aristotle
this is a lobe edition of aristotle's
nick mccann ethics
as you can tell it's been you know
beaten up quite a bit there's lots of
little sticky notes in here there's lots
of underlining
and writing in here as well and
this book probably more than any of
aristotle's works has has really gotten
it's uh i've gotten a lot of mileage out
of this particular
edition it's getting to the point where
you know the binding is starting to
break
maybe i'll have to get that fixed
someday in the future but i'm not
super concerned about it so long as the
words are still
legible and i can carry it around this
is spent a lot of time in a back pocket
or a hip pocket of
of you know one of my suits or
you know uh pants uh i carry this in and
out of indiana state prison
all the time when i was teaching there
and and you know working through
aristotle i don't know how many times
i've read through the work
but this is this is a real favorite of
mine
um i mean i like all my lobes but that's
probably the one i like the best
finally i'll mention this this volume
now this is kind of a funny story i
actually have three copies of this
in part this is the prayers and
meditations of saint anselm with the
pro-slogan
translated by sister benedict award
and for some reason
i had i had a copy before right with a
different cover
and i didn't lose it but i misplaced it
and i needed it i was doing a lot of
work on saint anselm
really from about 2002
through about i would say
uh 2016 2017
i still do work on anselm occasionally
but not not quite as much
and so i couldn't figure out where my
volume was and so
the you know my prayers and meditations
and i do a lot of work that
incorporates anselm's prayers and
meditations which by the way are worth
reading for their own sake even if
you're not
remotely religious or theistic just for
the beautiful
artistry and rhetoric and and the depth
of thought it's worth checking out
so we bought another one right we bought
we bought this copy
and then i ended up you know i put all
sorts of marginalia in here and
underlining and dog-earing pages and
stuff like that
then i misplaced this copy as well as
the other copy
so we bought a third copy i actually
have three
copies of the same work because of this
foolishness
of misplacing them but it's good you
know there's different underlining in
each of them there's different things
that i've i've pointed out
and it's a work that i
go back to i probably at least once a
week
read through one of these prayers by by
saint anselm somebody who i have a very
strong
attachment to so those are by my count i
think 11 books
11 volumes 11 particular physical copies
each of which has an important not just
intellectual value for me
but a personal story some sort of
connection and now i've shared it with
you
and maybe you'll find them interesting
i'll put links to all of these in case
you want to get get a copy of it
obviously your copy won't be my copy but
it you know you can start forming
relationships like like
this yourself to these great authors and
volumes
you